[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I
will be ranking the top 10 strongest
characters in the entire seven deadly
sins series after making videos ranking
every member of the demon clan and every
member of the goddess clan we received
very positive feedback and a lot of you
wanted to see who I think are the top 10
strongest characters overall all races
and clans included in this video I will
be doing just that and I will give you
my logic for why I am ranking them in
this particular order to make my
decision I will use power level
abilities battle capability and
accomplished feats to determine their
ranking that said this is not an exact
science so if you disagree please don't
hesitate to comment and give me your
reasoning down below I'd love to hear
from you
before we jump into the list I want to
give a big thank you to Grand Chase for
sponsoring this video
the official sequel to the popular Grand
Chase RPG has just been launched and it
is jam-packed with explosive real-time
action and strategy you can choose from
dozens of characters including all 19
that were featured in the original Grand
Chase and some brand new characters as
well and you can jump right into the
action taking on swathes of enemies at
the same time and using epic battle
combos to take them out in style you can
even set up a team of up to four
characters and hack and slash a barrage
of monsters at once one thing I love
about this game is that instead of
fighting every enemy one by one until
your hand cramps up you can gather a
bunch of monsters into a group and slay
them all in epic fashion not to mention
that you get to play with beautiful
magical waifu's and if there is one
thing that a 7 Deadly Sins fan like me
can appreciate its beautiful magical
waifu's this game is extremely rewarding
even for players who don't want to spend
a bunch of extra money so be sure to
click that link in the description and
check it out for yourself it's free
heads up I will be assessing each
character's strength at their peak so
that means that even if the character is
currently a lot weaker than they were
before or even if they are currently
dead I will still talk about them when
they were at their absolute strongest
point in the store
if you enjoy this type of video and you
want to see more be sure to leave a like
to let me know and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell please keep
in mind that this video will use
information all the way up to the latest
chapters of the manga
so there will be manga spoilers if
you're an anime only fan there are some
big twists coming up that you still
haven't seen in the enemy so this is
your warning and now let's get it
started at number 10 the goddess
Elizabeth in her original body Elizabeth
was a member of the goddess clan and the
daughter of the supreme deity of the
ruler of the entire goddess clan before
she was killed and then cursed by her
mother to keep reincarnating as a human
over and over again
which was her punishment for falling in
love with a demon ie male Yodas
Elizabeth was one of the highest-ranked
goddesses and she demonstrated
incredible power during the previous
holy war 3,000 years ago her exact
strength is difficult to pinpoint
because we don't have a power level for
her from back when she was a goddess and
she is also opposed to death and
violence so she does her best to always
avoid it but we do know that when she
was a goddess she took on both mon speed
and derriere e in there in do de forms
and was able to purify them with her
power knocking them unconscious and
reverting them back to their normal
demon forms in the past Elizabeth has
also demonstrated powerful abilities
directly related to empathy and these
abilities enable her to speak directly
to the hearts of her opponents and make
them lose the will to fight and we've
actually seen her convince an entire
army of demons to stop fighting the
Archangel male at one point compared
Elizabeth's strength to the strength of
meliodas and the Archangel lunar shell
so that places Elizabeth and the company
of some of the strongest characters in
the entire series and this is why she
lands at number 10 on our list at number
9 the Archangel Ludo shell the leader of
the four Archangels Ludo shell is
currently possessing the body of
Princess Margaret the sister of
Elizabeth Leonys as one of the four
Archangels Lou Rochelle has a gray
called flash which enables him to move
with super speed making him one of the
fastest characters in the series while
inside Margaret's human body Ludo shells
power level has been measured at 200 and
1000 but we can assume that in his
original goddess body which does not
have the limitation of human bodies Ludo
shell would have been even stronger
although it is difficult to say exactly
how much stronger he would have been
while some characters on this list like
Elizabeth want to avoid violence in
conflict Ludo shell is ruthless and
aggressive and he believes that the holy
war is a good thing because it gives him
the opportunity to destroy the demon
clan based on his strength and
ruthlessness but also keeping in mind
that we have seen him get overpowered
before by other characters including
Delhi Aryan Mon speed in Endora and also
zelgius with ominous nebula Ludo Shah
lands at number 9 on our list at number
8 King with fully-grown wings
Harlequin the king of the fairies also
known as the grizzly sin of sloth King
is one of the weakest characters in the
seven deadly sins when it comes to pure
physical strength however as the current
fairy king he possesses enormous magical
power and during the big mile slash esta
rosa fight in the manga King awakens his
full potential and attains a new form as
his fairy wings finally grow to their
full size coming to resemble the large
wings that the first fairy King gloxinia
had instead of the little baby wings
that king used to have and with this
transformation King attains a completely
new level of power now King is a
character for whom the last accurately
recorded power level is pretty much
meaningless since his last power level
was only about 41,000 but in this new
form King is on a completely different
level he is able to hear the hearts of
those around him essentially reading
their mind including their innermost
thoughts and using his true chasta full
and its many forms he is able to defeat
Maya Lin his corrupted form relatively
easily now when we think about how much
trouble everyone else was having
fighting mile after he had absorbed
multiple Commandments and when we think
about the fact that in this form a mile
seemingly destroyed
is they re and both sorry L ant army oh
it's easy to start thinking that maybe
King has now reached the status of one
of the strongest characters in the
entire series and while he now
definitely belongs in the top ten it is
also important to remember that at the
point at which King faced him Myles body
was already being torn apart from the
inside by multiple commandments so it is
possible that this was part of the
reason why King was able to defeat Myles
so easily nevertheless King wit his full
power awaken and his wings fully grown
is much stronger than he was before and
he is now definitely a force to be
reckoned with especially since all the
ladies know that when it comes to fairy
wings size matters at number seven
Merlin the Boers sin of gluttony Merlin
is the most powerful mage in all of
Britannia and we know that she has been
alive for more than 3,000 years in fact
thirty centuries before the story begins
Merlin knew and was close to the
original Elizabeth in her goddess body
Merlin was born in beli Alwyn a city
once known as the capital of the Wizards
and she immediately became famous due to
the fact that she was born with infinite
magic this infinite magic is so rare and
so powerful that the goddess and demon
clans both tried to get Merlin to come
over to their side during the previous
holy war and they each offered her
secret magical knowledge and abilities
in return for her support but rather
than picking either side Merlin just
took the knowledge offered by both sides
and because they were tricked by Merlin
the rulers of the goddess and demon
clans were so mad that they destroyed
the entire city of Vallejo Luwin
although Merlin survived of course as
should be obvious by now Merlin has
immense magical powers and possesses
many unique magical abilities one of her
special abilities is infinity which
enables her to make her spells lost
forever and she even used one of her
spells to stop her own body from aging
at age 30
making her virtually immortal and also
making her ESCA Norse eternal waifu her
magic abilities are considered to be in
a totally different league
from ordinary wizards and mages and she
even has an ability known as absolute
cancel which allows her to cancel out
and erase the spells of others Merlin
has so many different magical abilities
and items that there is no way to list
them all here but it's enough to say
that she can use everything from
teleportation to spells like perfect
cube and exterminate ray and of course
she possess a secret magical knowledge
from both the demon and goddess clans
because she succeeded in tricking the
demon king and the supreme deity so many
years ago on top of all that Merlin has
a mysterious ace up her sleeve called
the morning star of all Dan that we
still don't know very much about the
morning star wall Dan is the name of
Merlin's sacred treasure and it is clear
that it has insane magical power but
it's important to point out that it's
true nature and potential are still
largely a mystery which makes me think
that this particular sacred treasure
will play an important role in the story
at some point in the future in Chapter
292 we got a great glimpse of Merlin's
potential as she uses complex layers of
magic to cast multiple spells which
absolutely ruined Chandler and ku sucks
day and we can only imagine what else
Merlin has in store for us in the future
for that reason and of course because of
her insane magical abilities in general
Merlin ranks at number 7 on our list at
number 6 the original goal thir the
demon goal thir the person who created
the dog othor died long before the
current story of the seven deadly sins
ever got going but the more the story
goes on the more we come to understand
that Gotha played a huge role in shaping
the current world of the seven deadly
sins it is hard to say how strong he
would be in a one-on-one battle because
he died so long ago and his powers are
less about direct physical conflict and
more about long-range magic and mental
manipulation but it is clear that during
his lifetime goal there was an
incredibly powerful wizard so much so
that the demon king forced him to become
one of the ten commandments against his
will because the demon king thought that
Gotha was too valuable to the demon clan
to be allowed to simply do as he pleased
the original goal
was also the teacher and master of
Merlin so we can assume that Golder
taught Merlin many of the incredible
abilities that she possesses today and
his magic is so sophisticated that he
was able to create an artificial doll
and still make that doll one of the most
powerful warriors in the world a warrior
capable of becoming a member of the ten
commandments and of the seven deadly
sins and just like the doll go through
the original goal Thur had this special
ability known as invasion which allowed
him to read and manipulate the thoughts
and memories of other creatures as we
eventually learn in the manga go Thurs
magic was so strong that he was able to
end the previous holy war by
manipulating the memories of a vast
number of individuals on both sides of
the conflict including the demon king
himself even though we never quite see
him fighting an opponent one-on-one in
the traditional way the fact that the
original goal Terk and manipulate the
minds of so many creatures from a long
distance
including the mind of the demon king
himself means that Golder is overall one
of the strongest characters in the seven
deadly sins after all why even bother
getting into a one-on-one battle if you
can mess with your opponent's mind
before he ever gets a chance to meet you
face to face and now moving into the top
five at number five Zell drous zelgius
is the youngest son of the demon king
and he is acting as the demon Kings
representative zelgius has ambitions of
becoming the next demon king and because
he possesses power that he borrowed
directly from the demon king himself
sometimes referred to as the power of
God even the highest ranked demons like
Chandler and Cusack are both impressed
and intimidated by the potential power
that zelgius possesses although I feel
that Zell drous definitely deserves a
spot on this list he is one of the most
difficult characters to actually rank
accurately for one thing the highest
recorded power level that we have for
him was recorded long before the recent
events in the manga that power level was
61 thousand but a lot has changed since
then and zelgius could easily be three
times stronger than that now if not more
the other reason why I think cel just is
so hard to rank is that I don't think he
has shown us his full potential yet as
the direct representative of the demon
king he has unique powers the no other
higher ring
demon has and there is no accurate way
to predict the true extent of his power
in the video where I ranked all the
demons from weakest the strongest I
actually placed zelgius behind the
original goal third but with the latest
chapters in the manga giving us a better
idea of the extent of Zelda's true power
I decided to place him ahead of goal
thir this time around some of Zelda says
known abilities include Desiree which
lets him create a portal to a specific
target and strike the target down with a
lightning bolt and ominous nebula which
allows him to generate a dark vortex
that sucks in all living things and then
instantly cuts them to pieces when
thinking about how strong zell just
really is we can't forget that he almost
killed Merlin during the core and arc
and she was barely saved by Elizabeth's
healing powers and when zelgius used
ominous nebulae on Eskin or Merlin and
the Archangel lunar shell at the same
time he was giving them a lot of trouble
and he was only stopped by Eskin or when
he reached his most overpowered form
known as the one the Archangel looter
shell whose grace flash is known for
giving him incredible SuperSpeed admits
that ominous nebula is actually faster
than his grace and for all these reasons
zelgius makes it into the top 5 on our
list at number 4 askin or askin or is a
40 year old human and if that was all he
was then he certainly wouldn't be
anywhere close to the top 10 strongest
characters in the seven deadly sins but
he was born with a very unique power at
night ESCA noir is by far the weakest of
the seven deadly sins and one of the
weakest characters in the entire series
but as the Sun begins to rise each day s
cars power grows immensely every hour
until it reaches its maximum height at
noon as his power grows so does his body
he becomes incredibly tall and muscular
until he reaches his peak at noon each
day at noon s Connors power is at its
highest point for one minute and at this
time s Kannur is able to enter a state
known as the one in the past Merlin
stated them when this happens s Kannur
is easily the strongest of the seven
deadly sins as he becomes an invincible
incarnation of power the name of s
Kannur sacred treasure is the divine axe
Rita a heavy battle axe which he uses in
conjunction with his special ability to
deal devastating them
two opponents later in the manga we
realized that as canora's unique ability
is actually called sunshine the divine
grace that once belonged to the
strongest of the four Archangels my L
but somehow this incredible power passed
on to s Kannur because of the wild
fluctuations of his power between day
and night it is virtually impossible to
measure the true extent of s Connors
power especially when he is in the state
known as the one his power level has
been measured at well over 100,000 but
judging from his feats and his ability
to effectively challenge meliodas esta
rosa and zelgius while he is using
ominous nebulae it is clear that at the
peak of his power s kannur is way
stronger than 100,000 however before you
scream out praise the Sun s kannur is
number one and proceed to smash your
laptop in anger that I ranked him at
number four we have to remember that as
a human s kannur does have some clear
weaknesses that keep him from being
ranked even higher on this list for one
thing the peak of his power lasts for
only one minute a day and for the rest
of the day he is much weaker especially
at night what's more a high ranked demon
like Chandler can actually force s
Kannur to turn back into his weak
nighttime form even in the middle of the
day by using darkness which is the
demonic ability to block out the Sun by
surrounding everything with darkness as
a human he is also not immortal so he
could technically be killed especially
if he is caught by a powerful enemy
while he is vulnerable such as at night
lastly using the form called the one is
known to strain s Connors body making
him potentially weak and vulnerable as
soon as the effects of the one wear off
it is absolutely true that under the
ideal circumstances s Kannur is one of
the strongest characters on this list
but because of the clear weaknesses that
I mentioned he lands at number four on
our list at number three Melly Otis the
oldest son of the demon king Melly Otis
was cursed by his father so that he
cannot die or he can technically but he
just comes back to life and this makes
meliodas essentially immortal although
every time he is killed and comes back
to life he comes back with less of his
genuine emotions so he becomes more
cruel and ruthless after unlocking his
demonic powers and while in his assault
mode Melly Otis's power level was
at 140 mm but that is before malleolus
begins absorbing five of the demon Kings
Commandments in an attempt to challenge
the demon king and remove the curse that
was placed on him at this point in the
manga the power of meliodas is
definitely well over 140 mm and we could
assume that if he successfully absorbs
the five commandments which would amount
to a quarter of the demon Kings power
meliodas could easily be pushing a power
level of 300,000 we will have to wait
and see how powerful the new malleolus
is going to be but even before this
future powerup malleolus was shown to be
able to take on zelgius esta rosa and
Cusack at the same time on top of that
in purgatory meliodas emotions meaning
only one part of meliodas are able to
face off against the demon king with the
help of bond and wild but well this is
definitely an impressive feat it is
important to know that at this point
meliodas is still no match for the demon
king he managed to land a blow on the
demon king only after sixty years of
fighting him unsuccessfully with the
help of wild and bon and he managed to
do it only after finally learning to
unleash his original power but of course
after he absorbs the commandments and or
after he is reunited with his emotions
and becomes whole again Mele Otis's
power will rise exponentially and at
that point we may have to reevaluate
this list but right now I have to place
him at number three at number two the
Archangel mile back when he still had
his grace sunshine lunar shells younger
brother mile is confirmed to be the
strongest out of the four Archangels and
a single most powerful warrior of the
goddess clan among the goddesses his
strength is second only to the supreme
deity even without his grace called
sunshine which is currently possessed by
eScan or miles power level is believed
to be over two hundred thousand and
although absorbing multiple Commandments
definitely contributed to this if we
just look at how strong s Kannur is
thanks to sunshine despite being just a
human it is easy to conclude that mile
in his far more powerful goddess body
using sunshine or maybe even using the
one would be an unstoppable force
during the previous holy war miles
strength was compared to the strength of
Mellie Otis and after meliodas switched
sides and decided to join the goddess
clan the only way to give the demons a
fighting chance and stop the holy war
from turning into a war of complete
annihilation was for the original goal
third to manipulate the memories of
everyone who knew my el including my
himself and make him take melioidosis
place as the love of the ten
commandments
once this occurred the goddess clan no
longer had a chance to defeat the demon
clan outright so they decided to
sacrifice their own physical bodies in
order to seal the demons away inside the
coffin of eternal darkness now I know
that a lot of people down in the
comments are going to say that peak
meliodas is stronger than peak mile
because Mellie Otis is the main
characters so of course he will
eventually become stronger and yes that
is very likely going to happen once
meliora succeeds in absorbing the five
commandments or maybe even all ten
commandments however as of the making of
this video I think that we have to
conclude that my El with sunshine at his
peak would be stronger than mellitus
before he absorbs the commandments and
since we still haven't seen what Mellie
Otis is capable of after absorbing the
commandments I chose to put mile ahead
of him for now but if you disagree it's
totally cool feel free to give me your
reasoning down in the comments below and
finally at number one Lord Twigg oh I'm
only kidding guys everyone knows that
Lord Twigg owes power cannot be
contained by any single series or
franchise so at number one we have the
demon king and the supreme deity the
number one strongest pot is shared by
two beings at the same time the ruler of
the demon clan and the ruler of the
goddess clan and although you might
think this is some kind of cop-out and
that I should have found a way to
determine which of the two is stronger
if we go by the information that we have
so far all we've been told is that the
demon king and supreme deity are
extremely powerful that they are the
most powerful members of their
respective clans and that they are both
evenly matched the demon king is the
father of meliora sons eldress and he
created the ten commandments by dividing
his own power in half and then granting
1/10 of that power to each of the
commandments so if we put all ten of the
commandments together
all should measure up to only half of
the demon Kings full potential the demon
king also has some extremely opie
abilities including the ruler a magical
power that lets him reverse all attacks
used against him so that instead of
hurting him they actually make him
stronger he can also manipulate the
elements grant powers to others as was
the case with the commandments and plays
nearly unbreakable curses on people as
was the case with meliodas the demon
Kings exact power level has not been
mentioned yet although based on the
power of the individual Commandments we
can speculate that the demon Kings full
potential may be well over 500,000 we
could be tempted to think that because
the demon king gave up half of his
powers to the commandments he may have
been more powerful than the supreme
deity if he had kept the powers to
himself but we have to remember that the
supreme deity also gave the power of the
graces to the four Archangels and the
strength of the Archangels is comparable
to the power of the commandments so we
can't really assume that the demon king
gave up more power to his subordinates
than the supreme deity did and speaking
of the supreme deity she is the mother
of the goddess Elisabeth and as I said
before she has the power to bestow
Grace's upon the Archangels she also has
the ability to create nearly unbreakable
curses such as the one she used on
Elisabeth to control the elements and to
destroy entire cities she apparently has
immunity against all demonic curses and
in general the supreme deities abilities
are believed to be super effective
against the demon clan which could
indicate that in a one-on-one battle the
supreme deity would actually defeat the
demon king because her powers seem to be
super effective against his type of
power but that is just speculation since
we've never actually seen the supreme
deity in action we don't have any sort
of power level for the supreme deity and
we haven't seen much of her because she
is believed to reside in the celestial
realm with that said if the information
that we have so far is true and the
supreme deity is really as strong as the
demon king then her power level could
also be well over half a million which
would still be much higher than any
power level that has been revealed to us
up to this point and this means that the
supreme deity and the demon king are
definitely the two strongest characters
in the seven deadly sins at least for
now and that is it the top 10 strongest
characters in the seven deadly sins
ranked let me know if you agree with
this list and if not then definitely let
me know what you would change and why as
I said at the beginning of the video
this is not an exact science so your
feedback and input is welcome and
appreciated if you enjoyed this type of
content and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know if you're
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification
valve if you want to give us ideas for
future videos and stay in touch with all
the latest updates be sure to follow us
on twitter and instagram at anime uproar
as always thank you all so much for
watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you